While social networking is a useful tool for communication,...
...allowing people to integrate further with like-minded individuals,...
...occasionally, overuse can lead to an inability...
...to cope with elements of normal life.
Knowing if you are an overuser involves identifying key signs of addiction.
This can vary from person to person,...
...but typically indicates a strong dependence on the social network.
The solution is to wean yourself back into real life slowly...
...as sudden moves can be dangerous.
Once you are back in the real world,...
...genuine face to face networking can take place.
Note : You will have to temper your previously unfiltered opinions.
When visiting someone, writing on their actual wall is not acceptable.
By now, you'll be slowly remembering how normal people operate...
...and remembering that sometimes, actions are more important than opinions.
Once you're socializing in the real world,...
...you can move on to finding that special someone,...
...though do remember: do not insert your credit card...
...in order to convince them to get naked.
By now, you would have successfully spent less time on social networking sites.